que tout est bon qu'on est tous là je
vais mourir les deux chat youtube switch
au moins j'ai envie de dire on fait du
lourd à va falloir que je reprenne les
liens aussi à gauche à droite mais bon
je préfère vous faire la prépa en direct
comme la dernière fois
parce que au moins ça permet d'être au
taquet donc le lien du club j'ai chopé
voilà ça c'est fait je vais pouvoir le
mettre sur le tchat
ça s'est fait une première fois aussi
déjà on est déjà déjà on est sur un
début que j'ai envie de dire qualitatif
des gens un des buts stream qualitatif
parce qu'aujourd'hui en a marre les mecs
on a perdu la dernière fois contre
l'iran j'étais pas bien
aujourd'hui j'en ai plein affaires ont
gagné et j'ai un medef qui a joué en
plus le match contre l'iran il m'a dit
j'ai été là on a perdu mais il vrai jeu
c'est à lui aussi l'a fait les points
il a fait 2 sur 2 il avait joué il avait
joué qu'un match moi j'ai fait trois et
demi sur 4 juillet dix essais la res
c'est la presse les mecs c'est l as donc
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de ça on met
les points où il faut quand il faut et
salua renault 84,31 florian brunet julo
tard qui est la télé un peu tôt jules
alors fait voir les équipes là moi j'ai
envie de voir les teams je m'inscris
déjà au match je vais vous faire une
capture d'écran sérieux pour le moment
on peut les farcir honnêtement on peut
les farcir là pour l'instant ce que ce
que je suis en train de voir ça me fait
c'est plutôt quelque chose qui me fait
cheap plaisir donc on est sûr sur une
composition de type bonheur de type
heureux on est en train de les manger
les amis l'argentine en sueur c'est à
dire que là les jaguars argentan
il ya plus de jaguar voilà c'est là ils
sont en en deux chevaux quoi c'est à
dire que bon c'est nous qui avons la
jaguar dégage toi qui prends la deux
chevaux on échange de voiture je ne veux
plus te voir var va roulant peugeot 206
c'est intéressant comme voiture
donc j'ai envie de dire on est bien vous
m'avez encouragé sur le discorde vous
m'avez dit la dernière fois tu as fait
deux ennemis sur trois et demi sur
quatre ça va être dur de faire mieux
mais vous m'avez dit aussi c'est pas
grave tu es là pour motiver faut qu'on
gagne le match tu d'accord avec vous
c'est
ces collectifs ces collectifs ici et on
a on a besoin de toutes les forces en
présence pour leur coller aux argentins
il y en a marre je suis en plus je suis
un peu vert parce que vous savez que
j'aime beaucoup le rugby et le match
d'aujourd'hui contre l'ecosse il n'est
pas très bien passé j'ai envie de te
dire l'arbitrage il reste un petit peu
un petit peu au travers de la gorge
parle pas du carton rouge pour avoir ce
qu'il y ait deux cartons rouges parce
que parce qu'il ya coup de poing il ya
carton rouge
mais ce que faut regarder les trois
cravate est ce qu'on regarde leur jeu et
ce qu'on regarde ce qu'ils font dans les
rucks au bout d'un moment c'est sûr que
si tu regardes qu'une équipe ça ça va
très très vite donc je suis un petit peu
s'installer à ce niveau là et moi
l'argentin j'ai envie j'ai envie j'ai
envie qu'on le massacre si tu es donc la
premier match d'entrée on joue on joue à
1 + 1 on a pour le mans une belle équipe
mais il faut il faut qu'on se renforce
tout ce qu'on s'inscrive il faut qu'on
fasse mal salue le charpentier j'espère
que tu joues le match j'espère que tu
joues le match est appliqué un scandale
ce match là et c'est impressionnant le
français comme cela c'est ça faisait
longtemps que j'avais pas vu ça ça fait
longtemps que je n'avais pas vu ça
commence à ce qu'il faut participer au
club de la team france victor colin et
puis dans un deuxième temps tu pourras
aller dans tournant alive
comme toujours pour jouer les matches
par équipe sur check points comme
premiers matchs 21h deuxième match 21h20
je vais jouer les deux premiers matchs
les mecs il faut qu'on combatte les
argents par là y'a pas moyen il s'en
soit au classement là il ya un gars qui
s'occupe de ça ils s'appellent adrian
jamais ce qu'il est dans le tchat
et quand je pense à un arbitre à
valenciennes où elle s'était l'arbitrage
ya 15-20 ans en top 14
quand tu pouvais pas aller faire une
victoire à l'extérieur quoi
donc il va il va enfin on peut les
prendre faire gaffe s'ils peuvent se
renforcer en dernière minute
mais là pour le moment on leur fait
super mal
pour le moment c'est plus une équipe
qu'on a assez c'est plus le quinze de
france et ses 32 france on joue contre 4
pause argentin la saison ils ont tous
attrapé de coronavirus en argentine
qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est ce qui se
passe ils sont ils sont en quarantaine
sans internet c'est quoi ou 14mg pas
comment ils appellent ça c'est quoi elle
c'est quoi le délire des argentins là je
comprends pas cela françois baqué encore
dans l'eau chat si vous pouvez venir sur
ceux qui sont sur le twitt ch bitstream
avec l'autre si vous pouvez venir sur
sur czech com fr c'est un bon coup de
main je comprends pas ce qui se passe
que tu argentins ils sont décimés
l'argentine est décimée il n'y a plus
personne
il arrive qu'ils viennent en nombre au
dernier moment et ben ils vont ils ont
intérêt à venir nombreux jeux pareil
vous parler d'eux par les tchétchènes
sais pas pourquoi je ramène deux forts
on va les faits c'est ouais on va on va
les manger faut qu'on les mange dans
tout les cadences du coup pour ceux qui
jouent souvent ces matches ça se passe
comment c'est aux vainqueurs des trois
matches c'est un score général sur les
trois matches c'est quoi le c'est quoi
la règle moi je suis pas venu ça alors
déjà je suis avec mes 120 kg je suis
fait des amis sérieux vous avez parlé de
charpentier edge pas désolé des échos
vous avez eu des échos salut mouche à
merde salut salut tu as eu tu as eu des
échos pleutres bonsoir anne et chien
s'appelle pas un museau en et chiens
d'ailleurs est ce que ton est ce que ce
n'est pas museau 12 finalement ton
pseudo
je suis à nantes pour rejoindre la
tribune france ça n'est pas valide et
wet inquiète il va être sur le coup
c'est sur ce chat qu'il faut a dit
gaston 83 00 à toulon représente gros si
si ça lui cyril of toulouse représente
gros parce que toulon pilou pilou aller
les amis on les mange les amis on va
gagner aujourd'hui on va le gagner ce
match les amis il y en a marre il
na marre et ya de chasse pro bras c'est
un chat bram les professionnels lui
attention cercle av
on ne sait plus où on est leandro daniel
savoie la sas et ça ça fait plaisir
délirante et total vont lui va délibérer
ça y est nous dit un peu le un peu le
tempo kwarta culto le culte du car on
sait pas c'est à dire juste ya justin
yano et ben voilà cette joie qui est là
mais oui petit mais voilà des renforts
de poids avec seb on est avec des gens
sérieux on va aller manger les argentins
ce soir on va les bouffer les amis on va
bouffer argentin à ce soir faites-moi du
bon du bon steak argentin là il y avait
un resto argentin que moi je te portugal
s'appelait je crois qu'à autre chose
voilà il dit faisait exploser de la
bonne grillade aller les amis on veut on
veut du steak de buffle on va aller
faire griller les amis les argentins
doublaient vingt neuf qui arrivent pas
assez ans qu'il a pourtant il est fort
alors il s'attend en tout les vingt neuf
ou qui viennent aussi pour les bouffées
faut que tu passes sur le club france et
après tu vas sur sur czech comme comme
si tu allais jouer une partie en live et
tu vas dans tournoi c'est quoi un peu le
plat pour les gens qui viennent d'un peu
d'argentine qui connaissent un petit peu
c'est du florent pagny grillé c'est quoi
ce délire je me tape je joue en équipe
où je regarde il faut que tu joues
ludwig là on a besoin de tout le monde
là les jeux m'a dit que taper des 10700
c'est maintenant qu'il faut les taper
c'est maintenant les amis et pour
participer au tournoi je remets le lien
allez hop
le lien est là chez les amis comme à la
coupe du monde mais voilà qu'il y a même
tapé en contrat de travail
la frappe de ben ammar les amis elle est
pleine lucarne
elle est pleine lucarne la frappe de
pavard allez on leur remet des frappes
de pas rares dans la gueule on y va les
amis la frappe de pavard pamart second
poteau et et salua jean 65 dans 15 8 on
les en casque ouais il y aura deux
matchs en 21 21 heures 21h 22h
assad or voilà sadorge est pas simple
allez on bouffe de l'assad or j'aime
bien le nom asador je pense à dire un
truc crié tu vois un truc griller la
viande grillée je pense adore les
grillades argentine
bon allez on va falloir aller chercher
moi je suis pas très chaud en bullet en
ce moment je m'entraîne pas trop mais
c'est pas grave j'ai fait tap la semaine
dernière à l'e3 son faucon faut mettre
les poings par tous là les mecs je
compte sur vous aussi la dernière fois
j'étais un peu fer de lance pour pour
essayer de vous emmener dans mon sillage
mais là aujourd'hui vous êtes tous des
fers de lance on est tous des fers de
lance tout p 29 qui va aller défoncer
regardez-moi ça alexis 18,02 il doit se
dire qu'est ce que je fais dans ce dans
ce match j'ai 1000 points de moins que
mon adversaire leterrier il va le
déterrer alexis 1802 leterrier et il va
l'enfoncer dans le trou après ça va
aller faire très très mal starlight
externe sean ça va faire mal
regardez regardez moi c'est différent
c'est le côté français lass et voilà
c'est ça qu'on veut voir des plus 600
lots surtout les échiquiers
on m'a appelé on m'a dit les argentins
sont forts je suis pas au courant je
sais pas peut-être eu des échos je
savais pas alors cette équipe
d'argentine et ouais non mais à ce n est
bien sûr qu'il ya cette scène qui va
faire mal alors là on fait mal je pense
qu'il va y avoir son pote set dub est
aussi et ça va faire très très mal cette
équipe de france on va gagner tous les
matches d'ici quelques semaines ou
quelques mois il y aura plus personne
pour nous prendre les amis plus personne
ne ça sert à notre table les amis fais
attention adrian chan cette équipe va
devenir monstrueux su être dépassé par
le monstre que tu as créé plus un seul
match on va perdre ce sera fini ce sera
fini les amis est-ce qu'on peut
s'inscrire sans pour un match ou deux
bref on peut l'oublier ça va faire très
très mal je vous le dis tout de suite on
va voir s'ils arrivent tous en nombre à
la fin mais j'y crois pas trop
je pense qu'on va je pense qu'on va les
bouffer je pense qu'on a tous fait de
l'aca d'or ce soir
on va bouffer de la s'adorent faut qu'on
se rattrape pas ce cas la semaine
dernière contre l'iran ce n'était pas
joli joli
je viens à buenos aires je suis un
samouraï givet exactement arme un jv
horrible match contre les écossais j'ai
mangé ma casquette toi et moi aussi
stade cheikh mais c'est justement pour
ça qu'on vient ce soir on vient pour se
détendre après ce match contre contre
les écossais et les amis je peux venir
jouer avec mimi les lots waie tué avec
des amis sérieux à sa dope en fait à sa
dent asadho c'est pas web à sa douce
logiciel grillades
yoann on est bien d'accord on est bien
d'accord alors à se venger contre les
argentins là je crois qu'on est là on a
une bande de français très énervé on a
une envie c'est de cesser ses des
bouffées quoi alors on n'est pas très
nombreux dans votre équipe 1 ce soir
malgré tout aller inscrivez vous pas
grave montrons qu'on est plus nombreux
que fait faisons peur avec le nombre
même si vous jouez pas si grave
au moins on fait peur et ça lui et anne
ont fait peur on fait peur au pire on
est on est mille tu vois on leur dit
voilà qui est qu'est-ce qui a maintenant
c'est quoi le problème
ramenez-nous des grosses équipes tu nous
diras adrian cham quand est-ce qu'on
joue contre la russie à eau contre
l'ukraine qui apparemment des grosses
équipes on va venir avec des gens
sérieux
peut-être qu'on pourra demander un
certain vlad t'es bien connu dans le
milieu
russie le 15 mars là c'est c'est
dimanche prochain on va falloir venir
avec des amis sérieux un bref pendant un
certain temps mais plate et ça mais ça
m'étonnerait qu'ils jouent mais il va
falloir qu'on les prenne les rues st on
va faire de l'asadho avec les russes
aussi un bon les russes ont à faire du
porche
on fait quoi on fait du pain on fait
quoi avec les russes on a quelques
remplaçants sur le banc pour encourager
l'équipe way comment participer nicolas
bas il faut s'inscrire à l'équipe quoi
dans la team
mais là c'est à la cph une équipe qu'on
a là il ya là il ya tout le stade qui
veut jouer avec l'équipe de france
là on est là on est plus c'est plus du
onze contre onze là c'est plus du quinze
contre quinze c'est à dire que là il ya
les hooligans dans le stade qui veulent
rejoindre l'équipe de france c'est quoi
long du toit je trouve pas sûr tu as
comme en tournoi non mais faut faut être
dans le club les amis poètes dans le
club je suis dans l'équipe france
comment je pouvais prendre inscrire il
ya tout qui a toutes les indications sur
le lien que vous envoient les amis ont
fait des peines mais ni avec les russes
seraient c'est pas mal les pelmeni ces
genres de petits raviolis avec de la
crème et du poivre ses très bons amis je
viens de valider 12 personnes et ils
sont venu à l'idée
et voilà are you win qui est là mais
voilà mais tu fais plaisir c'est d'être
venu nous nous porter renfort
mais dimanche prochain du coup gros
match contre les rouscoff les roscoff
qu'ils ont plusieurs grands maîtres ça
peut être un match un peu un peu piège
mais j'ai envie de dire quand tu vois
des noms comme bananes vertes comme elle
l psychopathe à progression cette pente
et rafa talith vix comment tu peux avoir
peur toupet 29e 899 comment tu peux
avoir peur les mecs qui vont mettre une
grand maître ils vont prendre 16 0 ils
vont prendre 16 0 les amis c'est plus
des grands maîtres qu'il faut c'est des
super grand maître sinon ils n'y
arriveront pas ils n'y arriveront pas
facilité à l'équipe de france ils vont
se faire manger sur les quatre coins du
terrain les amis ils n'auront plus une
case sur l'échiquier
les 64 cases sont occupés les amis il va
y avoir que des pièces bleu blanc rouge
ça va être bleu regardez ça va être bleu
ça va être blanc et ça va être rouge les
amis ça va être le drapeau français sur
tout l'échiquier
c'est ça qui va se passer les amis et on
voit pas les chics et parce que je fais
n'importe quoi mais vous allez bientôt
le voir c'est le drapeau bleu blanc
rouge les amis vous allez voir sur tout
l'échiquier les amis c'est le drapeau
bleu blanc rouge
il est partout ce drapeau et il est sur
les échiquiers chase point coop aussi et
parce qu'on est français voilà on fait
peur à tout le monde avec notre drapeau
vous pouvez faire comme moi chez vous si
vous voulez vous chauffez le drapeau
bleu blanc rouge qui est là qui est là
sur l'échiquier qui peut s'asseoir à
notre table maintenant et dire j'ai un
drapeau sur un échiquier de check point
com qui qui peut faire le drapeau quel
pays aujourd'hui peut faire son drapeau
sur sur un échiquier de chaises comme
personne
personne ne peut y arriver cette chaise
comme qui a fait les couleurs par
rapport au drapeau français
ça a été ça a été prouvé en italie peu
aussi mais parce que je suis moitié
italien donc du coup j'ai des richesses
comme je suis d'origine italienne
est-ce qu'on peut aussi faire le drapeau
italien ok ok ok les amis c'est vrai
c'est vrai mais qui peut s'asseoir au
dessus de ces deux pays
personne les amis personnes notre
drapeau bleu blanc bougé la non le
drapeau est lgv est on ne peut pas le
faire voilà ouais c'est bella et la
russie pourquoi peut faire mode son
drapeau pascal a copié sur nos couleurs
c'est pour ça bon allez il reste 7
minutes là on continue à s'inscrire à
fond que l'on est fou - yade riz et donc
on va continuer voilà il ya cristal qui
est venu dans l'équipe pour renforcer
mais ce qu'est ce que ça fait mal cette
équipe
qu'est ce que ça fait mal rolala comment
j'aimerais pas être villa dominicaux
savent a pu être viella dominicaux ça va
être ruinés dominicaux une ruine ça va
être après cette partie
il va être ruiné il aura plus une pièce
sur l'échiquier
il va même perdre son abonnement diamant
après ce match même l'abonnement diamant
va tomber les amis parce qu'on va aller
les chercher
bon allez ça commence dans cinq minutes
on est un petit peu sérieux mais on leur
fait peur ils sont tous partis normadie
au dernier moment ils vont mettre une
grosse équipe
bon là on attend où est cette grosse
équipe pour le moins déjà ils sont dix
non mais c'est ok alors il ajou pleutre
il ramène des gars un peu plus fort et
ils disent au moins fort de partir ou
pas de partir mais ils sont pleutre face
on voit que je dise un tout ça faudrait
que ce soit des ayatollahs de macron
donc
keep attendez je crois qu'il a un plat
de mâcon de vlad macron mais c'est qui
ce génie mais est ce qu'il est dans le
csac ce pur génie qui s'appelle black
d'ingres on attendait mais qui est cet
homme qui est cet homme les amis époux
tilke a juste en dessous ça s'invente
par les mecs là de macron et poutinka
mais on a en a on a on a une équipe
d'élite des pseudos là c'est quoi c'est
quoi le délire
non mais vous avez vous êtes c'est
l'élite du pseudo en plus le mec est
membre diamant poutinka qui est cet
homme qui sont ces hommes qui sont ces
hommes non mais venez venez nous dire
quelque chose dans le chat la page et on
peut pas on peut pas être avec de tel
génie sans savoir qui se cache derrière
vlad scanner et vlad macron ok tu
connais à vlad non mais attendez venez
venez l'aller mais qu'attend honteux non
mais vous n'avez pas le droit de pas
nous parler quand on ne peut pas on peut
pas rater de tel génie à temps d arrêter
les mecs là là là on est là on est sur
du très haut niveau
remontant de chatila disent mince ouais
c'était les scanner c'est moi mais tu
parles jamais en plus dans les attends
tu dois voir des trucs à dire mec
franchement le mec qui a le pseudo vlad
macron doit avoir des choses à dire on
ne vous passionne pas d'adversaire enfin
c'est non malheureusement
malheureusement la semaine prochaine
contre les rouscoff qui aura à y aura il
y aura de quoi jouer mais là cette
semaine des argentins looper l'argentin
et pleutre ce soir l'argentin et pleutre
ballet va falloir que je me je me
concentre un peu moins faut que je mette
en marche comme on essaie par infos que
vous mettiez les points aujourd'hui je
n'ai pas les points les mecs
aujourd'hui je ne mets pas les points
c'est à vous de mettre les points il ya
une limite de joueurs maintenant
bon ils ont quand même pas mal de monde
là qui arrivent les mecs sains soyez
restés concentrés l'un va falloir faire
gaffe quand même faut pas trop se rater
quoi si la même team contre les iraniens
à wayne on se serait fait pouffer stade
cheikh aussi je pense quoique dans le 1
plus en était on était chauds n'en
rester concentrés les mecs ses fans
derrière pouvoir vous mettiez les points
là contre les contre les cinq sens là
vraiment falloir taper les cinq sens les
mecs les cinq sens les pros on y
retourne d'accord mais continue à vous
inscrire quand même les mecs qui sont
qui sont bien classés continue à vous
inscrire continuez à vous inscrire quand
même
j'attends juste la validation
l'administrateur à l'administrateur en
sueur des bons élèves
l'administrateur qui peut même plus
jouer dans sa propre équipe quoi c'est
horrible l'équipe est devenue trop fort
toi allez inscrivez vous inscrivez vous
continuez ça va pas jouer sur beaucoup
de partis ce match malheureusement ce
qui aurait été clairement à notre
avantage la banane verte et la ouais ben
s'il fut tellement bah ouais mais bon
t'as une équipe d'élite 1 car cette
équipe regard cette équipe on est venu
avec des amis sérieux regarde gens
n'aiment pas ce rôle je n'arrive même
pas à ce rôle l'équipe les mecs
j'arrive même pas à ce rôle l'équipe
c'est à dire que cette équipe ccc
athlétique quoi c'est une équipe de
malades
c'est une équipe de malades
leur bricole je vous dis ces bases pas
si ça va falloir mettre les points et
voilà il ya voilà y'a zeev yassef qui
est venu yassef qui est venu voilà 2006
en bullet et ben voila tonton tu vient
renforcer l'équipe
il fait plaisir zz merci tonton merci
tonton devenir un peu nous en force et
devant ça fait plaisir on est renforcée
ont dit on est bien devant des biens en
arrière on est on est bien partout la
points faibles trop fort j'ai envie de
dire cette équipe
alors qu'est ce qu'on va alors faire mal
qu'est ce qu'on va leur faire mal on va
aller soulever sans les toucher c'est de
la télékinésie les mec aille à
l'étudiant tôt et est stoppé studios
l'ont essayée soudure à jerez lafleur
faire attention
l'estudiantes doaré 13 tension nombreux
diamant ça va ça va le faire ça va le
faire on est on est bien on est bien
bien bien
on se fait l'argentine ouais on se fait
la rue doit être fait gaffe avec cette
phrase on y tient on se fait l'argentine
ouais setteuse d'habitude salut a tous
première partie ce soir bal et 20
secondes
je veux remercier échiquier pour pas
oublié et on met tous les points là
tranquille
allez on se concentre moi je suis pas
concentrée du tout vous vous êtes
concentré c'est vous les amis qui fait
le match ce soir c'est vous qui mettez
les points les alliés allez on va
chercher les points on va chercher la
gagne plus que 2 où on allait je veux
que des potées pas les mecs que des
potées pas aller on est on est 50 poté
pas là allez les potées pas on va le
manger
rory tola mojito jambes d'appeler je
vais te boire les amis je vais le boire
ojito mais oui mais oui la petite troupe
offs qui est les petits pions qui vont
arriver au centre mais regard les trois
lions mais regard comment ils font
plaisir plein plein fer les amis ils
sont là les lions peuvent ils sont là et
lui je vais avancer aussi les lions sont
de sortie les mecs c'est le gang des
lions tu es un cavalier en 1/4 et oui
les amis va venir par là il va venir en
d6 les amis ce cavalier ce chevalier
j'ai envie de dire
il est venu sur la case des 6es ya le
fou qui va venir en quatre pour le cloud
et les amis il est cloué les amis
il est cloué et il va être attaqué la la
il a attaqué de partout il bouge plus
il bouge plus une oreille rory tôt il
bouge plus une oreille
il bouge plus une oreille mais il est un
peu relou alors on va prendre là et je
vais lui mettre une tour en d1 dans les
annes y aller son cavalier paix celle ci
touche plus à rien on va y aller on veut
prendre là et prendre là peut-être
gagner un pion le fou g7 il est triste
les amis ils voient plus rien ça fait
des années qu'ils voient plus rien il
est derrière les pions f 4 5 qui
tiennent tous y tiennent tous les pions
y tiennent absolument tout l'échiquier
on va prendre une fois on va prendre à 7
on va gratter un pion
on va gratter un pion et on va aller
jouer la finale parce qu'on est pleutre
les amis allaient la petite finale
tranquille ou à l'aube scipion à trois
ça tient tranquille j'ai trois ans tient
tout il rend ils rendent sont fous je
vais mettre le j'ai monté droit je vais
monter droit je vais monter le pion je
vais monter de cavale ça c'était idiot
je vais monter droit on apprend à
réfléchir un peu parce que pour moi je
laissais c'est quelque chose que je n'ai
pas encore réalisé de réfléchir à alors
on va naître une courant des huit on va
peut-être passer par là on va lui coller
un échec et on va faire tourner vital on
va échanger une fois on va échanger une
fois on va venir la chute avec la tour
maintenant on va venir en b 8 on va
aller gratter ce pion ok on va venir en
paix si c'est sur wii fit son frère f5
les amis ça y est les amis on est en
train de tout manger les amis ça y est
le pion et six tombes
d'ailleurs je vais prendre de la tour je
vais faire un échec
je vais revenir en pays six balles et il
abandonne aller 1 0
sarr matches automatiquement à les
jumelles jus mais le deuxième point là
les jeux pointe une deuxième fois allez
faut que juan cole de que voilà au moins
on mais on met l'équipe sur de bons
rails
j'ai pas j'ai pas le score au delà de ça
mais si si je pointe deux fois ça va
faire du bien ça fait du bien à tout le
monde ça libère toute l'équipe de voir
les points qui rendent comme ça ça vous
fait vibrer par contre je vais faire
aussi un style austère que j'en vois
quand même g4 g5 g4 quand même dans ta
gueule
histoire de voile à eux de montrer un
peu comment on est je suis je suis pas
venu seul
bon j'ai peut-être faire ces cinq chefs
où le ça est pas grave je recule déjà je
fais peur allez on va lui bouffer un
pion ça au moins c'est ti par et
maintenant je vais jouer à gran aucun
joue dans l'esprit à fond dans l'esprit
c'est peut-être prendre avec le pion
mais bon on va quand même jouer
tranquille on va quand même faire grande
parce qu'on veut ce fair play soit le
foot hier par angers 6
le roi qui va grand roque et on est tous
là les amis c'est en train de ces en
train de faire mal côté français joueurs
français qui va viser le qe3 maintenant
le pion à 3 en grande difficulté et rory
tôt rory tôt attention attention
l'échangé d'amaury toya food et 3 enfin
deux variantes il l'a vu bien joué de la
part du joueur du joueur d'origine
argentine qui voit les tactiques en a
mais maintenant c'est le pion en d4
qu'il va falloir surveiller il va
arriver ce pion les ali tension d'un
point f4 échange des dames
quelle technique du joueur français qui
envoie son pion passé manche s'est
envolé les amis c'était peut-être pas
très bien joué cette histoire c'était
même très mal joué et je mette une tour
en d4
je fais un peu nawak je veux faire
bessin ces cinq baies 5 sur voila je
fais retour échec et c4 a donc faut
qu'ils prennent en premier et j'ai pas
le temps de faire ses 4 je me suis à je
me suis liquéfiée ballon va quand même
la jouer pour la gagne quoi qu'il en
soit à quoi qu'il se passe
le roi va monter petit on va partir en
c4 le voir argentin qui est fébrile
l'argentine est fébrile les amis ça
c'est bien jouer une nouvelle fois il se
crée le pion passé je monte le roi
à monthey droit j'ai commencé à monter
lyon continue
encore il va faire un échec et c'est moi
qui vais donner les échecs en premier je
vais donner un premier échec ici j'en
donnais un deuxième ici est le troisième
s'arrête matt deux heures les amis les
points sont pointés les points sont
pointés les amis on a gagné les amis de
0 facile facile les amis sans aucune
difficulté
on a mis 2 0 à l'argentine et on va voir
ce qui se passe à côté
ah le match est beaucoup plus dure que
prévu mais on mène on mène 38 à 38 à 20
je vous ai mis le score 41 41 à 22 c
l'écrasent ada les amis celle écrasa là
on les a mangés
on les a piqués à vif ils n'ont pas
existé dans ce dans ce match les amis
ils n'ont pas existé
ils ont été ils ont été dépassés par par
l'équipe de france on va regarder le
maître fide de leur équipe contre contre
progression 7 qui progresse bien dans
cette partie c'est le cas de le dire est
cette petite blague ecoplus qui n'est
même pas drôle mais c'était vraiment
facile le petit 2 ra que j'ai mis 44 23
il faut pas hésiter à faire enfler le
score un côté français on n'est pas là
pour faire des cadeaux on n'est pas là
pour donner des points le damien d'alger
et six dames si c'était précis c'était
bien joué c'était assez facile aussi
ça fait toujours plein de commencer par
par une bien grosse victoire bien grâce
à 45,23 il n'y a plus assez de partie
alors que are you who are you en danger
are you qui souffrent bullet seb 7 qui a
perdu la première en bullet ce n'est pas
sa spécialité le bullet aurait mais là
il va gérer il va égaliser
il va envoyer le pion il va envoyer le
pion b battu l'envoyer peut-être plutôt
quoique il va mettre laurent b 4 à ses
adversaires qui gigote
il va faire crisser 5 mais ça va faire
pousser 600 qui va qui va apporter son
point allez c'est fini c'est fait pour
seb ou là ils menacent encore kébé 4 il
fait face à un adversaire assez vicieux
qui a fini par lui planter à celle qui a
craqué à l'essai mais celle qui est
peut-être plus gagnant il s'est pris la
petite la petite tactique ou regarder f5
et roi des cadres d'am-dam ces cinq
échecs s'il vous plaît monsieur d'accès
trois matches
s'il vous plaît monsieur sébastien joie
ça c'était joli ça c'était joli bien
jouer sébastien et et progression 7 qui
a gagné au passage très joli très jolie
celle qui nous fait un math
un match dont il a le secret bien joué
il a égalisé 1 partout il a mis les
points
il ya eu ce qui reste encore des parties
pour encore en rester un peu que le
match soit pas j'ai fuschia me qui a mis
son poing aussi que le match soit pas je
crois que c'est fini un nom il reste il
reste une partie qui va être une défaite
pour pour le joueur français vite
qu'elle est forte à faire passer un juan
cruz arias des arènes tina dé buenos
aires est ce donc là la technique de
gains c'est de mettre le cas le roi en
b6 et cavaliers ans et cette jolie tons
mats m ça peut abandonner côté français
donc le deuxième match qui va commencer
à 21h20 dans dix minutes
voilà le score final l'équipe de france
qui gagne 56 30 c'était pas c'était pas
si facile facile hein on aurait pu
penser mieux alors à filer sur le
deuxième match les amis et on va voir un
peu un peu la tête des équipes est ce
que on est aussi l on est moins dominant
ana le forgeron qui est venu forget on
est moins dominants sur le deuxième
mais on va on va avoir
ça va ça va rentrer la côté français là
ça va être un peu chaud là ça va être un
peu chaud rory toronto il doit se dire
j'ai déjà de prendre 2 0 faudrait pas
que ça finisse par 4-0 kouadio y toros
sueur ou rory tôt attention ito faut
peut-être se désinscrire la non où je
vais trouver du travail au rythme tu vas
voir c'est quoi l'annoncé deuxième match
en cinq + 2 c'est un deuxième match je
vais trouver du travail rory tôt ou ccc
ont entendu c'est vrai ça passe quand
même vrai tu vas voir barioz qui revient
mais là là là à rory thoai à juan cruz
arias
elle retrouve arias qui est venu sauver
rojita tension est aussi un mec plus
fort que moi qui viens the bad the state
qui va jouer mais il était que 2100 en
longues parlons gambeat sont peut-être
plus nombreux en 5 plus de chez pas bon
sexe et plus derrière qu'on fait un gros
écart ça qu'on a une belle équipe un
ramenez moi les russes dimanche prochain
ramenez moi les russes
crystal est là il est qu à l'heure en
argentine je veux même pas savoir doit
être me dit quoi on sert à rien mais
regarde moi cette équipe un pion une
chaise points comme trois diamants déjà
tu prends des comptes diamant dans la
gueule d'entrée quoi beaucoup de
diamants
regardez moi regardez moi le nombre de
joueurs regardez-moi la profondeur du
banc les amis on peut faire rentrer du
monde les amis on peut faire rentrer du
monde tellement nombreux regarde moi ça
on sait même pas on sait même pas où on
s'arrête on vous allez tous jouer
dimanche prochain je vous rassure
non c'est une ligue anatolien c'est pas
pour le fun on s'amuse pas à la tension
1 les russes il ya beaucoup de mon doigt
ils sont 200 dans l'équipe généralement
on m'a dit donc ça va être sérieux deux
sens et chaud et généralement je crois
qu'ils ont si cette grand maître devant
donc il va falloir la semaine prochaine
il va falloir faire malin les mecs ça
risque d'être un peu plus compliqué je
vous le dis tout de suite je suis
passionné nombreux d'ailleurs sur sur
les streams ce que j'ai et j'ai le chat
puisque la commune en double prat forme
sur youtube et twitch vous pouvez me
dire mais l'impression que vous qui
s'est bien ses matches
j'en profite pour vous demander à 397
sur twitter s est pas moins que ça
marche pas mal
c'est plus sur youtube qu'on a qu'on a
du mal avec la chaîne chaise comme s'est
plu sur la chaîne bitstream kia du monde
va recruter un peu pour la russie
travaille dur les champions sont les
ukrainiens mais bon il va être dur à
prendre
interclubs la lune et pour cause pour
cruz de corona produits sur le net et ça
va de pire en pire
tout peut avoir 9 philippe maillard qui
je suis co 7 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 web reste
bien quoi plus tu es bas mieux c'est un
ça veut dire qu'on est plus forts en
mots ce que le mal le match va être un
peu chaud là devant parce qu'il n'y a
pas tant d'écart et l'eau que ça
j'arrive pas posséder les liens des
matches a pas que les gens aillent sur
le truc du club france du de toute façon
ils trouvent toutes les infos non la
procréation de chaises comme dans monte
avec les quarantaines je crois pas
qu'ils aient beaucoup de quarantaine a
priori zen on peut rejoindre la
compétition maintenant ouais faut que tu
te dépêches
nicolas du bas après je sais pas s'il
pourra jouer en haut de l'équipe je
connais pas ton vélo mais il faut que
faut que faut que tu chauffes sympa
aussi natalino sur youtube car la
connection rames trop que je suis sur
twitter
ouais après twitch c'est mieux mais un
pour les live petit panier qui
aujourd'hui j'ai eu interclubs moi perso
ouais bah les 1200 je fais pitié bas
cette semaine la semaine prochaine
devrait être là les mecs 1 puisque vous
pourrez jouer je le répète je me répète
je me contre répète mais à la semaine
prochaine tout le monde jouera
franchement franchement ça devrait le
faire
les troisièmes matches six mois par
exemple suis pas jouer en 10 + 2 vous
allez manger après lui d'ici la semaine
prochaine puis en irlande pas de chance
n est bon que tu auras tous les gros
matches pas rater la prod cette ligue tu
rates tu rates france russie
que fais-tu quoi
cricket n'y a pas d'adversaire way sont
pas venus nombreux
après ils sont ils sont pas mauvais
devant franchement c'est chaud du cal
but devant devant ça va se tenir à pas
grand chose va vraiment falloir que vous
rentriez les points derrière les mecs
c'est sévère c'est vers les deux mille
2000 qu'on commence vraiment à avoir de
l'écart est bien évidemment on attend à
ce que vous partiez les 930 un raid ne
meure je te prends pas sans bernière
groseille le charpentier tout ça on
attend on attend les points les mecs un
david 34150 si tu veux représenter le
département du 34 et va falloir gagner
un jeu vous met pas la pression mais
vaut mieux gagner
alpha zorro machin non non il va il va
falloir faire rentrer les points
l'américain met à faire rentrer les
points
c'est vrai qu'il va falloir pointer les
points après la vous n'avez personne
mais les points c'est là qu'il va
falloir les mettre les amis c'est là
qu'il va falloir les mettre les amis les
points ce soir par l'intérêt que leur
équipe petit lot d'incidents ce qui est
vrai mais ses parents l'esprit l'âme en
2007 79 on peut pas jouer huawei non
mais si je pense regarde ça rentre ça en
train de rentrer dans l'équipe adverse
les joueurs sont en train de les
rejoindre
c'est en train en train de faire rentrer
du monde l'an dernier en dernière minute
donc cyril of tu devrais pouvoir jouer à
mon avis je pense mon équipe allait
aller notre équipe est au complet et ils
sont en train de faire rentrer des gens
donc ça devrait passer
gestion avait prédit que vous faites
après le double de leur point n'est pas
sur ce que je sais pas
dur à dire parce que devant ils vont
être un peu un peu chaud du cal but donc
va falloir les prendre tu as il n'ya pas
n'y a pas beaucoup de profondeur en fait
et devant ils peuvent être pénibles
donc il va falloir les prendre un peu de
partout c'est vraiment là quand on
commence à voir 400 points d'écart c'est
vraiment là contenue commencé à faire
une grosse gifle donc ouais on devrait
mettre un gros score derrière et devant
chez pas
attention rapide analyse +2 faut pas que
les joueurs quittant masseret on verra
les joueurs quittent en masse et vous
faites remonter c'est le cumul des trois
matches adrian cham
normalement on va te quand même te
prendre une telle une telle avance que
ça devrait bien se passer quoi bien se
passer ne t'inquiète pas je lui enlever
ça je vais me suis concentré pour la
partie citron chocolat non mais bon
c'est devrait le faire les mecs
comment on fait pour rejoindre mes liens
mais elle est un peu en retard pour ce
soir
je voulais jouer mais je suis 1600 ça
passe même pas dit le turc sur 50 m du
rhin dur faut progresser syrine avis à
papa c'est vrai de pas grand-chose mois
les 5 plus de 1 à une française qu'à
valider de 3g 27,45 j'avais pas les
meilleurs et je vais pas 27,5 en termes
peu importe
un routier j'aime pas trop cette
variante
genre drame p6 un vrai tournant ils font
g5 c'est ça mais je sens que je fais des
essais je pense bon jouer cette position
je sais pas si c'est très bon mais je la
joue bien généralement que je mette le
fourbe et 5
jeunes est un pion à quatre c'est bien
bon pion à 4 ok je préfère qu'ils aient
b3 qui allait prendre dame prend fous
ces 5 fu et trois blessés ça va ok sur
gk je suis inquiet des quatre l'idée sûr
qu'il prend des cages il faut prendre
cet échec auquel il a vu évidemment
que je faire flouer 4,6 prends je prends
et je naviguerai avec la dame là bas et
surtout ses cinq peut-être considère
d'âme des uns pour venir attaquer a
réattaqué de l'autre côté de l'échiquier
a noté chez peut-être des cavaliers f 5
kg on prend et aussi ce qu'ils peuvent
rôder certains jours et ça je prends il
prend alors là j'ai deux écoles je peux
prendre du plomb
je prends de la dame sur échecs dames du
pont du leu prendre du plomb doit faire
de 2006 je me fais retour à 4 il fait
dan ici
j'aime est une tour en c1
si faible et si je mets la tour en c6
rock qui peut pas gdam g3 et mon idée c
b6 tour ces sept bons et pas que bon
j'essaye de jouer l'espace et le fait
qu'il a du mal à développer son roi fou
b4g dame crombez khadr qui est jolie qui
on prend on prend b8 3,7 fou j'ai cinq
un ouais il a pas mal de coups ok une
loi est fantastique la position
maintenant il faut encore finir
peut-être mon prochain coup c'est fou
des deux d'ailleurs essayer de s'en
prendre à sa et des six tours ces six
pour amener une tour je vais faire ça
qu'elle prend à 5 et sur bessèges le
tour c'est 6
elle a probablement joué food et 8 qui
doit être le meilleur coût je peux même
faire b6 à ce moment-là améliorée à 4 h
4 ok je vais prendre
ok je vais commencer à menacer du tour
c'est 7
moi je comme un pion de plus déjà
ok alors pour ces sept îles à tour prend
à 5
c'est son piège
j'ai peut-être fou des deux tours prend
un tour prince vous prendrez de tours à
huit échecs il veut jouer au con il est
tombé sur plus fort que lui il était
obligé d'échangés et il ya tours à huit
et damas trois échecs à la fin ça c'est
bien jouer au foot et 2
franchement c'est bien je jette un oeil
au score ont même déjà 8 2 parce qu'on
marque derrière mais fou des deux c'est
sale race et salle fou des deux salles
ça c'était vraiment sale qui est
peut-être dan des huit marche encore
kiev ou des 8
ok il abandonne pas encore
c'est pas encore abandon s'en tire
plutôt pas mal hein
non je joue un bon coup j'ai envie de
jouer dam des trois je me replace par là
je défends ça je trouverais fin je
prépare peut-être fou b4 en gros c'est
un coup multifonctions ce que fout des
cartes alors y avait d'un prend b5 et
j'anticipe un peu rock ok ça j'avais vu
mais je voulais juste prendre une fois
et faire h3 je peux prendre ça à tout
moment je met mon fou en b4 matou rang à
huit et puis après je réfléchirai
en gros je tiens un peu tout un cif et
dames c'est sage fait pousser trois
peut-être
alors maintenant qu'ils s'interdisent
rock je vais faire tours à huit dames
c'est 7 pouces et 3 est un étranger 3 et
je te prends par derrière
ok et maintenant fou g5y sous ceci est
un massacre c'est ait encore un piège au
le chenapan à je peux lui laisser le
piège était imad d'aig parce que ça
marche mais iliad avait faim et la
finale de pions elle gagne à 100% ou pas
bon je tends balle diable on joue par
équipe
je pense qu'elle gagnait mais je ne veux
pas tenter le diable ayad à 12h08 aussi
qui rentre je prends par devant par
derrière comme à la maison
ça en a l'habitude de traiter comme ça
et il faut avoir le droit à la peau et
le greta chambre msb
j'ai fait du sage et le droit ça va bon
si on peut plus rigoler quand on joue
aux échecs que fait-on qui à 24,4 quel
carton il n'y a même pas de match aller
nous une vraie équipe la prochaine fois
amenez nous une vraie équipe à 1,6 et
pourront nous ramenez nous ramener ça ça
sert à rien donc
donc on va faire ça à faire crisser 6
c'est comme à la maison les amis ouais
non je lui ai fait très très mal dans la
partie précédente
je fait extrêmement mal
hélas là je fais mal de nouveaux prêts
il ferait probablement le meilleur coût
d'investissement premier j'aimerais bien
mais sachez marpa je vais essayer de
faire ça et apte à s'en prendre à ça
mais je n'arrive pas à le faire marcher
vers 3,5 jugé d'humeur taquine
j'arrive pas à faire marcher ce que j'ai
envie de faire marcher le truc avec
d'anne decis à me ramener dans le
problème bon là je peux pas ce que je
touche ça il va prendre je reprends mes
joues cette position pépère sa ses
positions que j'aime bien pépère il se
passe rien j'aimerais bien sacrifier
mais là ça fait aucun sens puis on prend
g4 fou prend fillon prend gg que dalle
je veux apprendre comme ça je dois
rockets
cependant gdf 6 qui rôde puis on prendra
f6 il veut jouer des quatre parce que
c'est un problème je pas envie de
laisser en plus je me donne la casa 7
quai je maintiens tout renseignement
peut-être un jour j'ai france et deux
cavaliers prend gates pari fou prend un
f2 faire car et le set maintenant jouer
à ce fou prend fou prend tout reprend il
le voit là j'étais un peu con ce que je
pensais qu'il ne verrait pas 25le à ça
j'ai pas fou prend evans des six
malheureusement le faire
d'investissements non je me lasse là
ça serait content c'est un coup une
menace je vais essayer de claquer un
rêve de faire quelque chose mais bon
c'est un truc c'est que si je peut
bouffer ça et repartir alors ils
m'empêchent léger pas fou détroit
c'est relou ce qui va faire cailler b3
au prochain et qu'il y ait des 4 j'en ai
trop fait
tour des huit que faire des caprices
prise prise prise et je pourrais prendre
b2 à la fin de ce que je contrôle ça sur
kébé trois jours et tour des huit qui
est prend des quatre tours prend des
quatre et je ferai une double attaque là
dessus bon je masse des trois fêtes il
va tout est changé en d4
et quand je ferai fou prend des quatre
il aura pas énormément de coups puisque
j'avais a créé b2 et sur cavalière 3 je
fais tout prend b2 il n'ya pas tour b 1
je prends il reprend bien et j'ai agepa
tour c'est un échec à mes joueurs ils
fous des quatre le retour je protège ma
dame ça doit marcher
il peut faire b4 intermédiaire aussi ok
mais je prends une fois il prend je fais
fuglseth les b 4 est faible non ça doit
aller et ça je vais prendre une fois de
toute façon vite s'y prend là je prends
la jeu mais là cela doit être une
question allons bien et puis il prend
comme ça je mette une courant des huit
encore un coup une menace 6000 adhérents
à 4 déjà il a plu cavaliers à 4 il va la
mettre en å 1
qui est vraiment je vais faire cavalier
des quatre jeux menace de bouffer rien
du tout que je mette à tour en 17
il a survécu
c'est incroyable a survécu ça
quelle image à torrance et 7
j'aurais dû commencer par h67 être bon
est pas encore sorti d'affaires on mène
53,15 autre façon mais bon je n'ai pas
envie de laisser de jeu rien à envie de
laisser en faite agissent ici le fou ou
sur les cuisses un truc de ouf
je souhaite même plus vraiment des
masses mieux
que je rentrais dans la finale faut
trois fronts trois prises de trois
prises de trois baies 5 tours d un b4
bouffe bouffe cavaillé b5 tour ces deux
ok on va prétendre que ça va
ah ok ben je vais faire b4 une fois et
je voulais mettre la tour ans et de ça
c'est important à reconnaître la tour je
veux pas la mettre en deux je vais
mettre ces deux enjeux pas échangé je
vais m en c 2 le truc c'est que comme ça
s'il échange je rentre je pénètre et cif
et p3 havre ayant dû faire fous quatre
des cinq au québec fasse cavalier à 2
l'imaginé gf ou 4 quand même ok donc là
sur x h 5 il âgé 4 sur food et 3 il a un
truc aussi le faire fou et quatre
gymnases où pranger de déjà ok ils
l'empêchent je vais faire g5 et non
c'est pas terrible ça a
et je montre le roi une fois de toute
façon ça évitera les échecs
j'avais peur de tout reprend et tour des
quatre mais j'aurai à fouler cette fois
ci c'est je tape ça peut-être joué sept
d'ailleurs au prochain comme ça je
resterai tour prend b2 ouais non je
crois que c'est en train d'être bien est
ce que ça aille fait font des syndics
gauche veut sa mission tour des quatre
branches comme menace tous ces 4 donc il
va faire tour ici mais je vais faire
tourbe et de hockey il vous prend ça
j'ai vu mais je laisse pousser 4 que
j'ai envie de mettre un échec-avant dans
tous les cas ouais et maintenant j'en
vois
j'envoie il souffre le joueur français a
fait mal à tout l'équipe d'argentine à
ouais j'ai fait mal il y glisse où il a
pas vu la balle coup droit revers à elle
été bien velu salah biens techniques
72,16 adrian cham de mémoire d' équipe
de france on a déjà vu des massacres
pareil ou pas maintenant j'ai été solide
dans le dernier geste
non j'ai bien joué je pense que j'ai des
bonnes parties précis jusqu'à la fin aux
massacres 74 17
j'ai même pas un commentaire
les amis est ce que vous pouvez est ce
que vous pouvez me dire ce que vous avez
pensé du match baisse sans cette base
qui parle en chat un an
une villa nellcôte le coup de venir
ouais on les a on les a mangés 1 mais
bon on les a bouffés on leur a fait très
très mal
notre joueur français il a les noix par
mais non pas du chiqué
bref antastique hall non pas vraiment
bon je pense que le match en dise plus
de hadera tchanilé ou en fait il fait
quoi
kevin je suis émissions et l'eau et ses
ennemis de censure de chasse comme c'est
normal bah ouais y'a pas de même
le charpentier a perdu la première
arrête ça arrête ça hills où elle craque
le charpentier brian français la tête
gagner serait qu'un gagnable ça peut
être un
dans ça c'est nul à chaque fois rien à
faire pas faire près de la borne pas
toujours forcément mais la raison de la
jouer juste et n'eut droit des deux il
ya tristes sires qui a volontairement
abandonné ses deux parties pourquoi il a
fait ça c'est qui ce type il est ou non
mais c'est un gars qui veut nous nuire
quoi
je suis deg
réussir écoulement ça
sylvain laurent blanc j'espère magnifier
le mc de vite j'aurais pâli magnifique
mais sympa dans tous les cas c'est un
massacre un cas bravo les mecs on a en a
fait le taf
alors ceux qui veulent jouer des parties
d'entraînement 10 + 1 n'hésitez pas à
jouer le dernier match il ya celles qui
jouent moi je vais pas faire le dernier
en dise plus deux mais ça laissera jouer
un peu les pieds l'autre façon je pense
que le score est fait je pense pas qu'il
vous met 70 points
je pense que tous les scores ça va ça va
arriver on va on va faire le point
mais du coup ça nous place soit de
garrincha dans la ligue là que tu nous
expliques un peu c'est quoi il se passe
quoi en fait on leur a mis une pilule
ouais je pensais pas qu on leur mettrait
autant on les a découragés en fait on
est avant dernier on était dernier on
était dernier adrian chat vous foutez
quoi les mecs avec les argentins
s'étaient les derniers ex-aequo mais ils
ont ignoré ce qui a joué on va être
relégué les mecs là on va être relégué
là c'est quoi le délire à temps il va
tomber
toi à shanghai et ils ont fait mieux
réussies république tchèque avec les
mecs sont forts à temps non mais attends
les gars la russie on a plusieurs mais
les tchèques on est plus forts qu'eux ou
pas donc la masse est une compétition
que ce qu'il faut avant je suis à sept
et demi sur 10 donc j'ai envie terre
pour le moment je skie bien la compet à
munger plus l'autre match on en voit le
score final 82 à 21
c'était assez facile hein bravo à tous
vous avez tous a assuré on sait pas fait
peur ce soir dimanche prochain va
falloir par contre serrer les rangs
il va falloir aller chercher les points
ça va être chaud pour tout le monde dans
leur 10e craindre russie servir en
remercie chaleureusement sceptre est
devenu bien sûr vous remercie
chaleureusement cette d'être venu c'est
plus que le remerciait en plus il a il a
fait lé point notre seb dans dimanche
prochain je sais pas je sais pas comment
on fait
même pour les rapides mais peut-être
pour les rapides il ya des gens qui vont
venir lui dit être les rapides tu vas
pouvoir les jouer peut-être tu vas
pouvoir les jouer et rapide je pense que
ça va arriver de leur côté
khan qui dit après il ya une digue des
lots donc c'est logique oui bon on a
fait respecter la logique un jeu fait un
topo sur les championnats kevin m'a
remercié renshaw l'info que je comprenne
ouais le disent + 2 franchement les gars
qu'on vous fait des tournois les
prochaines fois tout fait plus de dix
plus de 1
vous faites le mais je veux dire quand
vous faites vos trucs là que vous jouez
en quinze plus de dix plus de machin
c'est relou garder garder ce format là
un +1 5 + 2 et 10 + 2 c'est pas mal ça
permet aux gens qui sont un peu fort et
qui ont peu envie de passer trop de
temps de jouer genre tu vois moi là j'ai
pris une heure et c'est cool et puis ça
permet à ceux qui à mes parties plus
longue de faire le dernier match en fait
s'ils veulent mais je trouve que c'est
bien là votre format jusqu'au
normalement c'était un peu lâche en
claquant quand vous aviez les matches en
quinze plus de machin enfin tu vois
ouais ça joue tous les dimanches et anne
je crois ce format il est bien là
sérieux vous avez le bon format là les
gars continuez comme ça on a bien kiffé
et après il ya des playoffs ou quoi
adrian chat vous faut vraiment qu'on
vienne avec des amis très sérieux ou pas
est ce qu il arrive qu'ils aient un truc
dur il y aura des playoffs lundi nous à
l'avant ce qu'on est les playoffs 1 on
va venir on va venir avec des gens très
très sérieux on va parler de coop
français statut d'aidé et qu on peut
plus sincères du coup si si tu peux
encore t'inscrire un jeu ramé les liens
le lien dateam france moi j'ai envie de
dire si on commence à streamé struc là
avec la team france on peut envoyer du
pâté du pâté très lourd
je vais arrêter la polka masqué ouais la
russie ça va être dur ce sera un match
de gala pour les français qui qui
viendront pour s'amuser c'est mieux
store bull être plus rapide puis lente
ah ouais c'est tu coules monsieur p soit
parce que j'avais un jeu un peu fort de
venir en début de match puis si le match
est vraiment serré peut-être on se
chauffe pour jouer dix plus de ce que
disent plus de deux façons ta personne
qui va vouloir le jouer donc là c'est
bien tu as pu l'être 5 + 2 puis après en
cas de match très serré peut-être tu
trouves pour du 10 plus de mdl qui
jouera dans la team france entre deux
rondes des candidats ouais ben c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que radjabov c'est la
vraie raison qu il voulait jouer dans la
team azerbaïdjan et ça lui a été refusé
ok mais les candidats que tu dois
commenté ben je ferai un ex tu as su à
la ncaa mon va tout faire mais du coup
je stream rsa sur bitstream avec des
gens sérieux
du coup on fera ça sur bitstream
on va pas tout faire sur tu as quand
même faire du coup ça me permettra de
faire un sort d'une pierre deux coups en
tout cas merci à tous d'avoir participé
c'était bien cool
bravo belle victoire on se quitte on se
quitte là dessus on se retrouve demain
pour des parties pédagogiques ou je sais
pas quoi pour faire un peu progressé là
parce qu'il faut que faudra qu'on à
niveau qu'on ait le niveau dimanche
prochain jeudi soir il y aura un stream
pédagogique avec vlad
bon voilà je sais pas ce que ça va
donner un meilleur oeuf mais ça va être
cool et à et du coup way sera sûrement
jeudi je sais pas j'ai eu des échos ce
sera sûrement je dis si tu as du brivet
si tu rates ça c'est pas de chance pour
toi tu seras à dublin
tant que mon sera on serait avec des
gens sérieux
donc voilà écouter il est temps de
savoir quitter il faut savoir il faut
savoir partir
bonne soirée à tous bonne chance pour
votre dernier match gagné encore
histoire